starting off with the smallest and one
of the youngest dragons to ever live we
have the last dragon this was the last
dragon alive following the dance of the
dragons and at its death reports claim
it was either the size of a cat or up to
the size of a small horse up next is
viserion the smallest of daer Targaryen
dragons eventually he was killed and
became enslaved by the night King
slightly larger than viserion is Regal
the second largest of daenerys's dragons
named after her brother rhaegar next up
is drogon the largest of DA's
targaryen's Three Dragons named after
her late husband krogo the next largest
dragon is marxis ritten by Queen rainy
Targaryen during aon's Conquest up next
is bolon nicknamed the black dread
written by King aegon Targaryen the
first during his Conquest his wingspan
was so large that his shadow could
engulf entire towns when he passed
overhead the final dragon in this list
and the largest to ever live is a wild
Dragon known as the cannibal estimates
put his length at over 175 ft long and
his wingspan at over 600 ft wide